this week was packed with redfall
backlash PlayStation Plus announcements
and some major hype over the new looks
at tears of the kingdom and Final
Fantasy XV so let's recap on Wednesday
April 12th redfall developer Arcane
Austin confirmed the upcoming vampire
hunting Adventure will launch with
quality mode only on Xbox series X and S
this means that the game will be hard
locked at 30 frames per second as a high
resolution is prioritized 4k on Xbox
series X and 1440p on Series S the dev
went on to reveal that the game will
receive a performance mode option in a
later update but unfortunately a release
window was not given the news caused
huge discussions all across the web that
ranged from civil conversations to toxic
behavior and console Warby but
regardless of which threads you pay
attention to the major takeaway is that
performance mode is generally favored
amongst Gamers especially for fast-paced
Shooters this is echoed in a poll from
Jeff Grubb as well as the comment
section to a Gamespot news episode in
which I asked about quality versus
performance before this news was even
revealed at this point in the life cycle
of the series consoles 60 frames per
second feels like the new standard these
30 frames the end of the world no is it
gonna make a fun game boring no however
it is a bummer to know that you own what
is marketed as the most powerful console
yet you're locked at last gen frame rate
for the time being on a major first
party AAA release but it's important to
keep in mind that Game Dev is
complicated and the scope of the sandbox
that redfall takes place in could be one
of the reasons why resolution is being
favored over frame rate in a previous
interview creative director Harvey Smith
also mentioned that the game was
developed under covid-19 pandemic
challenges and frequent power outages if
you've had your eye on redfall hit the
comment section and let me know if
you're still interested or if all the
updates have killed your enthusiasm for
those of you that only have a
PlayStation you aren't gonna play
redfall anyway so what can you play this
week Sony announced the addition of 16
games to his Playstation Plus game
catalog headlining the new selection for
PlayStation Plus extra and premium
subscribers is Kina Bridge of spirits
2022's delightful action adventure in
which you take on Shaman duties and grow
a small tribe of adorable creatures to
help you solve puzzles but if you'd
prefer something less wholesome and more
unrelentingly violent then do maternal
should quench your bloodlust the
follow-up to 2016's Doom reboot do
maternal dials up the action Carnage and
chainsaws to absurd levels as you battle
against the forces of Hell also before
we switch gears shout out to Mighty Doom
alright I know it's a mobile game and it
has a lot of micro transactions and
mobile trappings but I don't know it's a
good time like it's a good time waster
um check it out if you haven't but okay
you can face even more demonic threats
in Wolfenstein to The New Colossus as
you guide BJ Alaska weights on a mission
to evict Nazis from the US of a there's
also slay the Spire which helped
kick-start a whole new genre of
roguelike deck building games ubisoft's
live service Extreme Sports Action game
writers Republic and Tango Gameworks
classic survival horror game The Evil
Within for more relaxing Pursuits you'll
be able to download and play Bassmaster
Fishing Paradise killer and the Charming
Sackboy a big adventure this month all
these games are coming to the service on
April 18th and now for your weekend
homework you gotta watch the new trailer
for tears of the Kingdom as well as the
gameplay from Final Fantasy 16. even if
you're not interested in these games
you're going to want to check these
videos out for a chance at passing this
class and if you've made it this far
into the video thank you you're a real
one as you've probably noticed Gamespot
news will be moving to a weekly format
but we'll be getting a big revamp as it
does along with a completely new slate
of programming that our team is hard at
work on based on what I've seen you
should be really hyped for what's to
come but for now thanks for watching
this iteration of Gamespot news and I'll
see you again soon
foreign